>> NOTHING WAS EVER SAID TO
JOHN BOLTON I GUESS HE IS
WRITING A BOOK.
I HAVE NOT SEEN HIM.
>> Laura: PRESIDENT TRUMPED
DENYING DETAILS ABOUT
JOHN BOLTON’S UPCOMING BOOK.
IT SAID TO RELEASE IN MARCH.
SHOULD IT REALLY COME OUT IN AN
ELECTION YEAR?
HOW DAMAGING WOULD THAT BE
BETWEEN FUTURE PRESIDENTS AND
THEIR TOP STAFF, ESPECIALLY THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR.
FRED HAS KNOWN JOHN BOLTON FOR
30 YEARS AND TWICE SERVED AS HIS
CHIEF OF STAFF.
HE JOINS ME RIGHT HERE IN THE
STUDIO EXCLUSIVELY.
YOU ARE MAKING A PRETTY
REMARKABLE PLEA.
WHAT IS IT?
>> JOHN IS AN OLD FRIEND AND I
DIDN’T TAKE ANY PLEASURE IN
WRITING THIS PIECE TODAY.
I BELIEVE THE CONCEPT THAT
PRESIDENTS HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
CONFIDE IN HER NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISORS AND BE ABLE TO KNOCK
AROUND IDEAS, THIS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
WE WANT THEM TO CONSULT THE BEST
POSSIBLE ADVISORS AND KNOWS THAT
WHATEVER HE DISCUSSES WILL NOT
APPEAR IN PRESS OR IN BOOKS.
THE BEST THING WOULD BE FOR
AMBASSADOR BOLTON TO PULL THIS
BOOK UNTIL TRUMP LEAVES OFFICE
OR AFTER THE ELECTION.
>> Laura: THERE IS A LOT OF
SPECULATION, WHO LEAKED THIS
ACCOUNT OF THE TRANSCRIPT?
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE MANUSCRIPTS AT THE NFC.
A COUPLE OF NAMES ARE FLOATING.
IT’S A PUBLISHER TRYING TO HYPE
THE BOOK BEFORE IT GOES ON THE
MARKET.
IF IT WERE SOMEONE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE LEAKING THIS, WHAT
WOULD YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT BE?
>> I TAKE AMBASSADOR BOLTON AT
HIS WORD THAT THEY DIDN’T LEAK
IT, BUT SENDING SOMETHING SO
SENSITIVE TO THE WHITE HOUSE
DURING IMPEACHMENT HEARING AND
ALL THE BUREAUCRATS AT REVIEW.
I’M AFRAID IT WAS AN INVITATION
FOR A LEAK.
THERE IS A REPORT THAT THERE ARE
MANY PAPER COPIES MADE.
IF THAT IS TRUE, HEADS SHOULD
ROLL.
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN VERY
CAREFULLY -- THAT DOESN’T EXCUSE
THE DECISION TO SEND IT TO THE
NFC AT ALL.
>> Laura: I CONSIDER BOLTON A
FRIEND TOO BURIED HE’S COME ON
THE SHOW, OTHER SHOWS OF MINE
FOR 20 PLUS
YEARS.
HE KNOWS HOW THIS GOES.
HE IS NOT A NEOPHYTE.
HE KNOWS HOW THIS ROLES IN
WASHINGTON.
HE KNOWS THIS IS GOING TO GET
LEAKS, DOES HE NOT?
>> I THINK THIS WAS A MISTAKE TO
SEND IT TO THE NFC.
I DON’T THINK HE OR HIS STAFF
LEAKED IT.
THEY MAY HAVE ASSUMED IT WOULD
BE HANDLED VERY CAREFULLY.
I THINK THAT DECISION WAS A
MISTAKE.
IN THESE CIRCUMSTANCES, THE LEAK
WAS STRAIGHT LINED.
>> Laura: CHUCK SCHUMER SEEMS
TO BE IN THE BOLTON CAMP RIGHT
NOW.
WATCH.
>> THERE SEEMS TO BE A GIANT
COVER-UP AMONG SO MANY OF THE
LEADING PEOPLE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
IF IT WAS EVER, EVEN A SHRED OF
LOGIC LEFT TO NOT HEAR WITNESSES
AND REVIEW THE DOCUMENTS,
MR. BOLTON’S BOOK JUST ERASED
IT.
>> Laura: CHUCK SCHUMER,
JERRY NADLER, SCHIFF, ALL POISED
TO PUT JOHN BOLTON ON THE
MOUNT RUSHMORE OF HEROES.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY TO
CONSERVATIVES, REPUBLICANS, AND
OTHERS WHO SERVED WITH HIM?
>> THE ALLEGATION IS THE TRUTH,
THE PRESIDENT WANTED
INVESTIGATIONS OF THE BIDENS.
THAT IS NOT ANYTHING NEW.
ASSUME THAT IS TRUE, THIS WAS
PART OF A DELIBERATION.
IN THE END THAT DIDN’T HAPPEN.
WE WANT PRESIDENTS TO THROW
AROUND IDEAS WITH THEIR EXPERT
ADVISORS.
THIS IS BASED ON ANONYMOUS LEAKS
TO "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
WE DON’T KNOW IF THESE REPORTS
ARE TRUE.
>> Laura: THIS WAS A MOMENT
TONIGHT IN THE PRESENTATION BY
THE DEFENSE TEAM.
PAT CIPOLLONE TALKED ABOUT, IT’S
FROM A SATURDAY, ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
>> THEY ARE HERE TO PERPETRATE
THE MOST MASSIVE INTERFERENCE IN
AN ELECTION IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
WE CAN’T ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DECIDE
ELECTIONS.
THEY HAVE ONE COMING UP IN NINE
MONTHS.
>> THEY ARE THE ONES
PERPETRATING ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE THE DEMOCRATS
ARE WORRIED THAT THE AMERICAN
VOTERS GOING TO INTERFERE WITH
THE ELECTION OF THE NEXT
PRESIDENT.
IF YOU LISTEN, IT DOESN’T MAKE
ANY SENSE.
THE AMERICAN VOTER MAKES A
DECISION AND IT SEEMS LIKE THE
DEMOCRATS VIEW, UNLESS A
DEMOCRAT IS ELECTED, THE
ELECTION IS NOT LEGITIMATE.
>> Laura: WEDNESDAY LAST TIME
YOU TALK TO BOLTON?
>> I TALKED TO THEM RECENTLY.
>> Laura: YOU THINK HE’S
BURNING TO TESTIFY?
>> I’M NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
MY PRIVATE DISCUSSIONS WITH
AMBASSADOR BOLTON.
WE HAVE TO RESPECT THE CONCEPT
THAT PRESIDENTS HAVE TO CONFIDE
AND THEIR ADVISORS AND KNOCK
IDEAS AROUND.
HE CAN’T BE AFRAID OF HIS
DISCUSSIONS BEING PUBLISHED.
>> Laura: WE REALLY APPRECIATE